messieurs bonjour nous vous interrogeons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle singer view on aurait aimé
avoir un petit peu point de vue sur la
finance on va commencer d'ailleurs pas
les inégalités on va donner la parole à
hervé de carmoy hervé de carmoy qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur les
inégalités qu'elle croise aux états unis
et elle croise alors que la population
américaine croit il y a aujourd'hui 50
millions de sud américains dans 25 ans
il aura 130 millions il ya aujourd'hui
16 millions de dhs asiatiques ils seront
40 millions alors comment croiser il y
croise parce que les blancs c'est dire
ceux qui ne sont pas sud américains
noirs ou jaunes sont quinze fois plus
riche que les autres c'est un fait et
que les inégalités de rémunérations ne
cesse d'augmenter
quand je m'occupais de l'industrie
automobile américaine
le patron de general motors gagné 30
fois plus que l'ouvrier aujourd'hui
c'est 400 fois plus donc accroissement
sensible des inégalités c'est ça le
point de départ et vous vous en tant que
citoyen quand vous voyez cet
accroissement fou des inégalités qu'à
votre sens quelles seront les
répercussions sociales
au niveau de la population américaine
est peut-être au niveau de la population
mondiale au niveau de la population
américaine les
répercussions ne seront pas des
répercussions à la française les
américains vont pas se révolter
pourquoi parce que c'est un immense pays
et que
population et disséminés sur un
continent donc ce sera lent mais il y a
un début de rejet de ces inégalités qui
explique que le président actuel des
états unis
met autant l'accent sur la réduction des
inégalités et pourquoi est ce que les
inégalités se sont accrues parce que
les salaires des gens qui ont entrepris
et ont créé des affaires se situe dans
le milliard de dollars et que vous avez
des centaines de milliers de cadres
moyens qui voient leur niveau de vie
baisser pourquoi parce que l'éducation a
considérablement augmenté on pouvait
aller à l'université américaine pour
20000 dollars ans aujourd'hui il en faut
quatre vingt mille et parce que le coût
de la santé a explosé philippe béchade
qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire sur ce
que hervé viennent nous donner comme ça
comme information est est ce que vous
pouvez saupoudrer dans votre
raisonnement un peu les gaffes à google
facebook la californie qui souhaitent
faire sécession la californie voilà
plutôt la silicon valley classic en
valais qu'il souhaite faire sécession au
niveau de la californie qui souhaite
peut-être même établir des bases en
dehors des eaux internationales pour
créer ses propres règles philippe g
rebondir déjà sur la question de
l'éducation
effectivement on est sur une quinzaine
d'années pratiquement
parvenu un triplement des frais de
scolarité pour
des débouchés qui malheureusement
ne sont pas extensibles à l'infini
puisqu'il ya énormément de postes
d'ingénieurs qui ont aidé qui ont été
délocalisées vers l'inde je parle
notamment de l'informatique donc ne
reste aux états unis que les postes de
recherche très très fois tu
quand on regarde la composition du
congrès américain
sénateurs
et
renoue représentants on s'aperçoit
qu'ils sont plus de 70 % à sortir de six
universités américaines lesquelles on va
on les connaît tous c'est-à-dire
harvard
il l aime haïti et c'est eux
même cambridge enfin ce sont les plus
chers et ce sont celles qui donnent le
plus facilement accès soit à une filière
aujourd'hui qui est presque la terre
royal pour arriver à un mandat électoral
c'est-à-dire la filière du droit ou
alors la filière du business management
un businessman qui a réussi à l'image de
mitt romney tentant à un moment ou un
autre de devenir un homme politique
voilà donc là on a une sorte de
reproduction de l'élite
parce que tout ce monde là se cooptent
parce que on y met ses enfants dans les
mêmes universités et elles sont très
chères elles deviennent carrément
inaccessible donc ça c'est un facteur 10
n'a l'idée d' inégalités tout simplement
parce que les filières qui mène vers le
sommet de la pyramide
aujourd'hui sont réservées à ceux qui
ont déjà acquis les moyens
10 mètres qui mettront leur faut
repenser votre avis cure sur la
cooptation la consanguinité de certains
élite qui prennent des décisions pour la
majeure partie c'est quelque chose qui
choque évidemment notre auditoire si les
français s'ils et italiens suédois
danois puisque au danemark non seulement
les études sont gratuites en deçà des
étudiants sont même payés ils sont même
payés entre 7 et 800 euros par mois ce
qui leur permet de se financer au moins
une chambre et leurs études donc je
referme cette ferme que cette parenthèse
la aux etats-unis non ça n'a rien de
choquant
tout est payant et la qualité se paye
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
véritablement de
ça ne choque pas la population de se
dire que petit à petit les études
deviennent carrément inaccessible rien
il ya un système de bourses qui permet à
quelques très méritant d'accéder
justement aux bonnes filières mais bon à
part ça ça ne choque pas vraiment
l'américain méritants au quotient
caution politique
méritant quotient politique maintenant
ses lacets comme méritant avec avec ce
biais qui est d'essayer de favoriser
justement les minorités dites voyante
donc laisser de permettre l'accès à des
enfants la deuxième génération d'émigrés
chinois latino et cetera d'accéder
maintenant très rapidement sur ce qui se
passe en californie bon là aussi on
s'aperçoit que ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
à créer des boîtes qui arrive à trouver
des financements sortent également des
meilleures universités technologiques et
une fois que
on a réussi aujourd'hui le grand enjeu
c'est pas de maintenir
la suprématie américaine sur le plan
technologique pour une boîte c'est
également de s'affranchir totalement
totalement du système fiscal américain
les entreprises qui aujourd'hui sont
devenus des mutations des
multinationales ont un taux d'imposition
de 8% sur les bénéfices voire pour les
plus maligne et les plus proactives en
terme de
dissémination de leurs profits dans les
paradis fiscaux elle n'arrive à faire
tomber leur taux d'imposition moyen à 5%
alors on va rebondir là dessus avec
olivier berlioux de vie bergie bonjour
bonjour le taux d'imposition des grosses
sociétés comme facebook google qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez vous en dire est ce que
vous pouvez nous parler aussi des
luxembourg leaks oui on vous écoute
j'aimerais revenir d'abord dans un
premier temps sur les inégalités en
rappelant c'est un phénomène qui touche
tout le monde occidental depuis les
années soixante dix en tout cas c'est un
phénomène qui démarre aux états unis et
qui a touché très fortement les états
unis assez fortement le monde anglo
saxon et ensuite de façon un peu plus
modérées les pays type allemagne france
italie les conséquences de ce de ce
changement mentale parce que ce qu'il
faut bien voir c'est qu'évidemment
l'arrivée de ronald reagan aux états
unis accélèrent un ce mouvement ou de
croissance des inégalités mais ce qui
est assez intéressant c'est qu'il est
vraiment théorisé c'est une doctrine
c'est une doctrine et c'est peut-être la
première fois de l'histoire qu'on a ça
d'ailleurs quand on recherche plus
d'inégalités en se disant que finalement
les riches et en plus riches et bien il
y aura ruissellement sur les plus
pauvres et ça enrichira le pays ce qui
est vraiment nouveau ce qu'elle-même et
même les libéraux américains des années
fin du xviiie siècle et était très
libéraux et peu d'étapes il se disait de
but ce sera 15 radios d'inégalités au
final ici de but est de les augmenter je
peux je peux vous poser une question un
peu plus personnel est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une façon de
sélectionner les plus dangereux ou les
plus gris d'y aller plus cupides d'entre
nous le plus agressif dans le business
c'est en tout cas c'est une façon
d'enrichir encore plus l'élite l'élite
américaine on sait que les quelques %
les plus riches des états unis possèdent
la moitié à la moitié du patrimoine on
est vraiment sur des niveaux aux états
unis
un peu conscience en europe 1 mais qui
sont délirants terme en termes
d'inégalités et évidemment le les
conséquences de ce mouvement là sont
évidemment pas d'enrichir
la lettre bourges bourgeoisie ou quelque
part nouvelle aristocratie le nouvelle
noblesse la nouvelle noblesse russe est
une femme une vraie noblesse alors qu'il
va être financière qui va être aussi un
parfois médical là-bas vu les
spécificités du modèle de santé aux
états unis qui sont les avocats voilà en
gros c'est le trader c'est le trader le
pdg l'avocat et le médecin qui finissent
à avoir des niveaux de plusieurs
millions d'euros par an de revenus les
conséquences sont plusieurs heures dans
l'évident amant est la conséquence
sociale et tout le monde voit bien ce
que ça peut faire la voir en terme de
délitement social d'une croissance des
inégalités même si comme le disait hervé
dans le cas particulier américains on
est une société qui tient assez bien
face à ce modèle là puisqu'il ya
vraiment une une idée aux états unis
deux sites à jouer c'est ta faute et
chacun attend lloris à dire bah oui ben
je sais pas j'ai pas un rond mais je
suis mauvais en fait j'aurais pu devenir
président des états unis comme comme
obama ne l'ait pas fait donc c'est ma
faute il n'y a pas forcément de
raisonnement en disant oui m'attend j'ai
pas pu aller à l'école parce que ça
coûte un bras avec le banquier me
suivaient pas
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
qu'elle croit qu'il ya des effets
économiques ils sont extrêmement
importants en termes de captation de la
richesse produite par par un secteur
finalement improductif si je donne 1000
euros plus un ouvrier américain valait
le consommer local et faire des courses
donc il va faire tourner l'économie si
je me mets à donner 1000 euros de plus à
un multimillionnaire
avocat américain qu'est ce qu'il va en
faire eh bien il va le placer sur des
marchés financiers qui vont se placer
hors galimant td bull qu'on connaît qui
ont peut-être allez allez spéculer sur
le rouble en russie allait savoir en
tout cas qu'ils vont être enlevées de
l'économie réelle et donc qui a une
influence c'est bien sûr sur les packs
de croissance que connaissent le monde
occidental est encore en train de
croissance des pays en général et aux
états unis à tien 2,5 pour cent 2 à 3%
de croissance s'il ramène par habitant
il n'y a plus que deux et demi si
j'enlève les habitants
sud américains qui sont non déclarés
prêts plus que 2 % par habitant c'est
bien certes plus que plus qu'en europe
mais on n'a pas des analyses très fines
là dessus mais il est assez clair des
travaux de piketty cei sur les
inégalités aux états unis que si vous
regardez les 90% de la population qui
gagnent moins ou peut-être les 80 années
80 90 % dans cette masse la des états
unis et probablement en récession depuis
2008 et c'est les 10% supérieurs qui ont
peut-être une croissance de 10% par an
ce qui au final va vous faire tient une
petite croissance de 2% soit payée mais
faut bien voir qu'un pays qui coulera
une partie du pays importante qui coule
et une partie qui s'en sort très très
très très bien en particulier en étant
aussi aux dirigeants des entreprises
dont on parlait tout à l'heure et qui
est un bon éviter de payer des impôts ce
qui est en train de ronger viendront
reviendra vers vous concernant les
luxembourg l'x olivier delamarche
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez vous dire un
petit peu sur ce qui vient d'être dit
l'élu symbolique des inégalités
l'évasion fiscale à travers l'irlande et
de grands acteurs comme google facebook
qui pointe rouge et faute c'est plus sur
les food stamps d'accord a coûté est pas
si rond si si on veut donner des
chiffres vous avez à peu près 50
millions d'américains un petit peu moins
de 50 millions d'américains qui sont au
foot ce thème puis vous avez 60 % des
ménages américains qui ne peuvent pas
faire face à une dépense de 400 $ sans
emprunter les 400 dollars ou se les
faire prêter par par leurs proches
nous on vous tenir aux chiffres rend les
chiffres ils sont ils sont publiés par
le bls par
le béa et les différentes enquêtes de de
la fed de philadelphie et c'est donc
vous avez aujourd'hui
une une accélération de la pauvreté aux
états unis comme on en a jamais vu
depuis les années 30 donc
alors c'est vrai que vous avez des aussi
des
des prêts étudiants qui sont la nouvelle
bulle
probable derrière probablement la bulle
du pétrole mais vous avez une bulle qui
s'est constituée parce que les feraient
les frais pour pour faire face aux
études sont de plus en plus importants
et qu'aujourd'hui
le problème c'est que les débouchés sont
de moins en moins important c'est à dire
que vous avez d'aider des gamins qui
sent des de 80 mille dollars pour faire
leurs études et qui trouvent pas de
boulot sauf un boulot de serveur ce qui
va être compliqué pour rembourser les 80
mille dollars donc vous avez vous avez
tout un tas de choses qui qui ont qui se
sont considérablement dégradées depuis
cinq ou six ans depuis 2008 angot et
malgré une une considérable monte de 2
du standard à une course mais ça ça ne
ça ne réjouit que les 2 ou 3 us qui ont
des actions concernant concernant les
luxembourg l'x
sur les luxembourg lic ggg rien de gérer
un extraordinaire à dire moi ce que ce
qui me ce qui me choque aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est plutôt qu'on on s'occupe
de
de chasser
les
les quelques personnes physiques qui ont
mis sans milou 200000 bâle en suisse
mais qu'on continue joyeusement avec
l'irlande qui ferait qu'on veut
maintenir seulement dans l'europe parce
que c'est quand même un tel apport qu'
il faut les maintenir dans l'euro et qui
permettent aux entreprises aux grandes
multinationales de ne payer que 7 ou 8 %
d'impôt quand ils en payent 7 ou 8 parce
que quand ils sont suffisamment
puissants et négocie même 6 et donc
voilà enfin je veux dire on est on est
dans un dans une espèce de de haro sur
le baudet sur le particulier qui donc
grand père a mis 100 mille balles de
côté en suisse et puis que total grâce à
ça
face échapper un milliard de milliards 3
milliards d'impôts ça ça gêne personne
et aucun souci hervé pour résumer la
situation vous avez expliqué tous les
quatre ont réuni trivialement les choses
qu'il y avait une doctrine américaine
projeté sur la finance une doctrine vous
en avons discuté avec pierre connaissent
un as des affaires stratégiques d'une
stratégie projeter sur l'europe les
conséquences de la finance est ce que
vous les anticiper aussi ses
conséquences inégalitaire ce que vous
anticipez sur l'europe
hervé
inévitablement
mais où il a source de la principale
différence entre les états unis et nous
les etats unis ont refusé depuis un
temps de contrôler leurs banques elle
refuse de voir que les banques
américaines ont pris des risques énormes
d'abord la source première deyris et la
réglementation américaine de 1970 qui a
autorisé la rémunération des dépôts à
vue et comme les dépôts à vue ont été
rémunérés alors qu'ils ne l'étaient pas
avant les banques américaines ou un
manque à gagner énorme ce que vous
pouvez expliquer succinctement qu'est ce
qu'un dépôt à vue pour nos auditeurs un
dépôt a vu c'est quand vous avez
quelques milliers d'euros que vous
n'avez pas placé
dans des dépôts à 1 mois 3 mois un an ou
dans des actions qui sont en quelque
sorte assise sur votre compte à ne rien
faire bon ça représente des centaines de
milliards de dollars il a été ça
représentait 30 à 40% de du financement
de la liquidité des banques les utiliser
les dépôts de ces particuliers des
entreprises qui étaient là à 6 ou bien
placés dans leur compte et qui ne
bougeait pas beaucoup alors les ont pris
ça des soudeurs l'état a dit il faut les
rémunérer et comme il a fallu les
rémunérant sa entraîné une diminution de
40 à 50% de la rentabilité des banques
en fonction des taux d'intérêt donc
cette transformation la à
amener les banques à dire comment est ce
qu'on va gagner de l'argent alors il a
eu un deuxième ils ont autorisé ils ont
arrêté le lien entre l'or et le dollar
en navette entre le lien entre l'or et
le dollar les banques américaines se
sont vus
dotés
d'autorisation d'augmenter massivement
leurs bilans autrefois ya 30 ans le
bilan de la banque pouvait pas être plus
de 10 ou 11 pour cent plus grands que
les fonds propres de la banque
aujourd'hui on arrive selon les banques
à des taux de 50 fois plus grands 80
fois plus grands 90 fois plus grand les
effets de levier de 90 des effets de
levier de 90 à vous explique qui est en
ce moment dix mille banques américaines
depuis 2008 qu'ils soient tombées en
faillite parce qu'elles ont exagéré car
la réglementation a changé
vous parlez de réglementation pour
revenir sur ma première question
initiale les luxembourg leaks
on a vu quelqu'un exfiltré de
l'information concernant jean claude
juncker qui aurait organisé l'évasion
fiscale ou faciliter l'évasion fiscale
de traîtres avec très grands acteurs
mondiaux maintenant jean claude est à la
tête de l'europe est ce que vous pensez
pas que la réglementation est un peu
pipés ou tronquées dès le départ c'est à
dire que nous avons des élites qui sont
cooptés ou du moins sélectionnés pour
soi leur agressivité soir leur capacité
à raisonner ou faire perdurer un système
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que ces
fameuses luxembourg ces fameux
luxembourg l'x sont la quintessence même
de cette veulerie politicienne politico
financières
écoutez on peut pas le nier
il y a une tolérance à l'égard du 2-2
d'aidé européen qui enfreignent la loi
concernant la déclaration de revenus et
leurs déclarations patrimoine qui mérite
d'être contestée mais où est ce qu'on
peut mais sous quel point vous contestez
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
il ya une enquête qui a été été faites
et des députés européens ont reçu des
pressions pour se retirer tout cette
enquête vince un monde qui manque de
courage
il est indispensable d'avoir des
représentants de la population qui avis
dans l'intérêt à long terme de la
population et que ces flux de capitaux
énormes
qui ont été déposées au luxembourg
devrait avoir
été ailleurs de façon à servir la
communauté des pays qui constituent
l'europe ça demandera peut-être d'avoir
des hommes d'état et non pas d un
politique de carrière pour ça alors là
le choix des hommes et 1 p est une
grosse question comment se fait-il qu'on
est élu qu'est ce qu'on doit montrer
pour être élu est ce que le fait
d'indiquer qu' on va pénaliser les
riches on va faire respecter l'intérêt
général fiscale et on va prendre les
mesures nécessaires est ce que ça vous
fait élire vous usez jeu j'use et j'ai
un peu un point d'interrogation olivier
bourrouilh et
oui c'est une illustration que la fraude
est finalement au centre du système
et ce sur sur de nombreux sur de
nombreux sur de nombreux domaines c'est
bien vu quand les banques ont fait
faillite en 2008 il a fallu être
recapitalisé d'urgence est évidemment au
final il ya eu pratiquement aucune
sanction sûr sûr sûr les sur les
dirigeants aucune sanction instituée sur
quel est ce prime et ce prime sont assez
des milliers des milliers de fraude du
pdg jusqu'au
jusqu'au petit est employé aux petits
courtiers de base qui quand ils voyaient
un américain à 5000 euros de revenus par
an disait on avait cinquante mille ait
pu être gay toutes les déclarations pour
refiler sallabank mais moi qui a eu
aucune poursuite contrairement aux on
feuilletait la fin des années 80 et est
épargné caisse d'epargne fin des années
80 aux etats unis c'est des centaines de
procès il ya eu pratiquement
000 ici j'ai deux hors jeu les rolling
stones qui m'ont pour offrir les choix
les luxembourg l'x bon c'est un exemple
que nous sans boire a participé à
l'évasion fiscale des deux de ses
voisins européens comme le fait
l'irlande comme le fait le pays bas vont
cette fois ci la belgique sur certains
sur certains points donc on vous montre
ça montre qu'il ya aucune solidarité en
en europe interétatique et l'idée et
essayons d'aller tondre le voisin et a
dû piquer sa base imposable à certains
on en fait même
un modèle de ceux de ceux de ce système
au final mais en a une responsabilité
totale ce sens est assez c'est assez
frappant dans ce même
dans ce système dans lequel on n'est pas
ce qu'on dit parfois il est libéral
ultralibéral sur certains côtés oui on
voit très bien sur certains côtés oui ça
peut s'appuyer sur des théories 1-2
dérégulation totale façon milton
friedman mais dans la théorie ultra
libérale qu'elle tombait en panne en
tout cas une forme de cohérence au bout
d'un moment il ya une sanction mais
quand la banque on l'a dit réguler pas
au bout d'un moment les jours la banque
à un problème elle fait faillite point
final voire même n'y a pas de garantie
pour responsabiliser les gens donc en
tout cas dans la théorie libérale il ya
un moment une responsabilité une
sanction des gens qui vont en prison on
voit qu'aujourd'hui il n'y en a aucune
voire même qu'on promeut ceux qui ce
sont ceux qui se sont trompés on nous
vante le beau modèle européen alors
envoya aucune solidarité ceci étant
c'est notre faute aussi bien qu'on aille
pas trop chercher ce que fait google ou
ce que fait apple à partir du moment où
on fait une zone en europe où il ya plus
de frontières et on n'a pas homogénéiser
les taux évidemment qui va se trouver un
crétin quelque part qui va être moins
honnêtes pekin - dans la philosophie
générale qui va mettre comme l'irlande
un taux d'imposition sur les bénéfices
sausheimois 5 ou 10% évidemment tout le
monde va aller là tout comme si vous
voulez monter votre votre entreprise aux
états unis si on vous dit au texas et 5%
d'imposition ses 32 à new york et
réfléchissez un peu vous allez je pense
que vous allez au texas donc le problème
c'est bien pourquoi pourquoi on a fait
ça et en conclusion je trouve tellement
extraordinaire d'avoir mis juncker à la
présidence de la commission car on voit
que ce titre quand même il a organisé la
fraude fiscale en dorthe c'est pour
montrer sa vision jega voir juste un
petit mot lyon coeur un bon quand il va
avoir des problèmes économiques il va il
s'adresse à qui il s'adresse à pierre
moscovici évidemment le winner quand
même économique en europe et au pire par
moscovici il dira rien pour qu'on
s'occupe de la france il décroche le
téléphone qui répond harlem désir qu'un
ministre des affaires européennes pierre
qui a planté le ps en a mis là parce
qu'il fallait l'exfiltrer du ps a dit on
le met où on lui dédie relire en fait
non tiens on va le nommer ministre des
affaires européennes sérieusement ça
peut paraître un sketch plus vus de loin
quand même cette histoire je vais je
vais je vous passe la parole tout de
suite après je me rappelle d'une
histoire d'un
président américain inquiet et 10 du
mois un parent qui est dit à la sortie
de
la grande crise du jeudi noir c'est à
dire qu'il a été bombardé à la règle la
réglementation bancaire parce que il
connaissait très bien le milieu à ce que
vous pensez que c'est un kennedy le
joker
j'ai lu faire beaucoup d'honneur je
pense
voilà d'accord
non mais lol alors ce que disait je suis
tout à fait en accord avec olivier mai
le pire c'est que c'est dans tous les
pays comme ça la chine sans hong kong
les états unis 7 de la mer jeu on a on a
ça dans absolument tous les pays on en
parle là en europe parce que c'est le
sujet du jour mais vous avez ça
absolument partout donc des des systèmes
qui permettent de détourner la fiscalité
des états qui c'est vrai devenu
tentaculaire donc il ya une soupape de
sécurité sais c'est que je suppose comme
ça que je le joue en tout cas les
politiques c'est de se dire il faut il
faut un moment
offrir une une porte de sortie mais les
facs qu'on est con et un système qui
soit comme complètement corrompu juge
pas si vous avez il ya quelques tous les
ans vous avez
je ne sais plus quel organisme qui
publie la liste des pays et de la
corruption dans les pays la france est
très bien classé un très très bien dans
le négatif donc voilà on sait qu'ils
sont corrompus on sait que et là
malheureusement on sait qu'il n'ya pas
de sanctions je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec olivier bonjour vous
aurez des sanctions pénales
à une personne qui fait sauter une
banque
parce que là aujourd'hui à rien vous
avez une amende à la bnp de 7 milliards
de dollars 2 7 milliards d'euros par an
10 milliards de dollars 7 milliards de
d'euros qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
patron s'en fiche complètement il fait
un chèque mais qui est ce qu'ils payent
c'est nous c'est que vous êtes à la bnp
non senoussi partout de toute façon
c'est moins d'un pont donc partout parce
qu'en plus ils l'ont ils l'ont mis comme
chargé du type ce qui est énorme en
général les allemands ne sont pas
déductibles mais là c'est déductible
parce que c'est la bnp donc on le paie
mais en revanche les gains c'est pour le
patron et après quand il parle on lui
offre un joli poste mais si si si le
risque c'était de se prendre 10 en taule
il réfléchir à deux fois avant de faire
de bêtises philippe je pense que c'est
la définition même de ce qu'on appelle
la ploutocratie tout simplement la
collusion entre les milieux d'affaires
et les milieux politiques
moi j'ai plusieurs observations
observations à faire en ce qui concerne
la responsabilité des politiques
il n'y a pas de service après vente une
fois que vous avez élu quelqu'un les
décisions qui vont être prises
celles qui vont totalement échapper aux
radars des citoyens il ya
malheureusement rien à faire vous prenez
un gouvernement comme celui de la france
où vous apercevez que sur 30 ministres
il y en a deux qui sont passés par
l'entreprise qui ont une petite
expérience de l'entreprise les autres
sont surtout des politiciens
professionnels ils ne sont spécialistes
de rien donc le jour où il faut prendre
une décision un peu complexe un peu
compliqué sur la fiscalité
sur
sur la façon dont doit fonctionner le
système bancaire ce sont des
spécialistes dans le périmètre des
politiques qu'ils assument
le suivi de dossiers le traitement des
dossiers ensuite ça fait l'objet d'un
vote à l'assemblée les gens savent pas
du tout ce qui se passe parce que c'est
trop compliqué même le gouvernement
comprend pas grand chose à ce qui s'est
passé réellement et à la sortie on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya des conséquences
si les gens on avait eu conscience avant
de glisser un bulletin de vote dans
l'urne il aura dit surtout ne faites pas
ça enfin c'est ça c'est à notre
détriment ce n'est en effet qu'au profit
d'un cercle restreint de gens
qui tiennent pratiquement tous les
leviers financiers donc il n'y a
absolument aucun moyen de contrôle après
coup quand on a éludé politique et que
c'est politique confie
la réalisation
des réglementations européennes et
cetera il n'y a pas de contrôle
est-ce que vous avez terminé c'est exact
il n'y a pas de contrôle j'avais juste
une question c'est oui vas-y assez assez
politique assez fou là veulent à ces
foules aveugle ou à ces politiques leur
crève les yeux c'est soit l'un soit
l'autre est ce qu'on est entre les deux
à l'heure actuelle c'est à dire que
l'électeur n'a pas le temps dû au stress
économique de s'intéresser réellement à
la politique de la cité où c'est
vraiment réellement orchestré pour qu'
il soit complètement borgne ont
complètement aveugle par rapport au
déroulement des choses
je reviens à quelque chose de simple il
ya des lois ces lois ne sont pas
respectées en matière de fraude en
matière de dissimulation
elles ne sont pas respectées on n'a pas
à se plaindre
auprès des dirigeants il faut que
l'ensemble des responsables
sociaux des journaux et des pouvoirs
publics décident d'appliquer la loi on a
tout ce qu'il nous faut hervé le budget
de l'administration stis et en france
c'est moins que le budget de l'écologie
mais je sais mais il faut peut-être que
l'état décide d'augmenter
significativement le ministère l'obligé
du ministère de la justice et avec la
perspective de récupérer des milliards
mais elle est là et certains pays le
font je peux vous dire que la fraude
fiscale dont nous parlons est infiniment
moins grande en grande bretagne qu'elle
ne l'est sur le continent elle est moins
grande parce que les sanctions et les la
façon de fouiller les dossiers de les
faire remonter
que les gens soient multimilliardaire où
qu'ils soient en bas et plus forte donc
il faut encourager notre justice
nationale à prendre les mesures très
strict pour
forcer les gens à ne pas dissimuler les
quand on le trouve à prendre l'argent je
vais je vais donner la parole à olivier
delamarche juste avant on voudrait
souhaité rendre un petit hommage à denis
robert pour son enquête qui a réalisé
sur clearstream un journaliste qui n'en
veut et qu'on va voir demain pour son
avant première sur un film qui résume
son enquête olivier delamarche vous
souhaitiez rebondir oui mais je vous
souhaite simplement on a le le problème
principal c'est qu'on n'a plus d'homme
d'état depuis de gaulle
visiblement on a des courtiers en
scooter on a des gens qui n'ont pas
grand intérêt et qui qui sont à
bien loin d'être à la hauteur des enjeux
et de et de la crise actuelle donc tant
qu'on aura des gens comme ça qui ont qui
respecte tous le principe de peter qui
sont des incompétents placé là parce que
on pense qu'ils feront moins de mal là
où ils sont et malheureusement je pense
qu'ils font beaucoup de mal là où ils
sont on aura on aura ce type de réaction
pourquoi voulez vous que ces gens là
augmente le budget du ministère de la
justice alors qu'ils sont aux
justiciables et
tous et tout ce qu'il risque qu'il
risquerait tout si on appliquer les lois
la prison pour pour longtemps donc enfin
ils vont pas se tirer une balle dans le
pied tout simplement donc ils n'ont pas
du tout envie de 2,2 que l'ailé que les
choses évoluent comme ça ils sont bien
tranquilles c'est la nouvelle noblesse
les politiques en europe c'est la
nouvelle noblesse c'est à dire qu'ils
ont tous les droits qui n'ont absolument
de compte à rendre à personne
et
finalement ils vivent très bien et ils
n'ont pas du tout l'intention de changer
quoi que ce soit qui les mettrait en
risque dans ce cas ci il faut pas
compter sur les politiques pour
divulguer ce type d'information est ce
qu'il faut plutôt compter sur des
initiatives populaires ou des des
plateaux comme celui ci pour divulguer
de l'information et avoir une vindicte
populaire qui pousse la justice a amené
des gens devant à les mettre devant
leurs façons vous êtes un peu comment
ces stands cgt au pouvoir qu'en rêve
c'est qu'en regardant le journal de 20
heures que vous allez vous avez aimé
d'accord et c'est pas non plus en
écoutant les discours d'un pierre
moscovici ou vous d'autres vont donc
il ya qu'il ya quand même quelques
petites choses qui nous font décoller du
niveau zéro de la réflexion
philippe oui moi la vindicte populaire à
la fois je la trouve parfois
rafraîchissante voire peut-être
salutaire le problème c'est qu'elle se
manifeste souvent par une montée des
extrêmes des gens qui en fait d'instinct
comprennent quelque chose qui va pas qu
on enfume qu'en faisant ils savent pas
techniquement exactement quand les
choses se passent ils savent pas qu'en
derrière chaque député européen il y
avait trois ou quatre le bassiste
aujourd'hui il ya toujours environ 570
député européen il ya 15000 le bassiste
ils agissent tous au nom d'intérêts
financiers à part quelques ong qui ont
eu aussi quelques lobbyistes qui essaie
de faire quelque chose et quand on
regarde aujourd'hui la dissémination des
pressions exercées sur les uns et sur
les autres on s'aperçoit que comme on a
souvent mis au parlement européen des
gens qu'on essaie de recycler parce
qu'ils n'ont pas réussi dans leur propre
pays ils ne sont donc pas spécialiste et
quant à un grand spécialiste grand
avocat international d'un grand cabinet
basé à londres où luxembourg vient
expliquer que voilà la nouvelle loi que
le parlement de bruxelles va essayer
faire passer c'est pour un but qui en
fait est évidemment de nuire quelque
part à la collectivité et de servir
quelques intérêts particuliers
les les députés sont totalement
perméable et il ya évidemment comme je
t'ai tout à l'heure aucun contrôle en ce
qui concerne l'avs ont pu récupérer
beaucoup d'argent c'est évidemment dans
les trous noirs de la fiscalité
européenne
les fameux luc slicks ça veut dire quoi
simplement que le luxembourg accorde à
une multinationale et bien la
possibilité de négocier un forfait
fiscal pour les 18 à 24 prochains mois
c'est parfaitement légal c'est clean
mais je rebondis là dessus qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la loi macron qui a été
retirée concernant le secret des
affaires le secret des affaires là on
moi je pense sincèrement qu'on a
effectivement bien fait enfin il ya eu
beaucoup de réactions
bayer qui arrive effectivement qui émane
et
aussi bien des médias que de gens qui
ont un petit peu pris conscience de quoi
il s'agissait c'est à dire que si cette
loi passe et ça veut dire que n'importe
quelle entreprise
pouvait poursuivre n'importe qui au
prétexte que ça pouvait nuire à la bonne
marche de ses affaires mais tout
simplement un peu une extension de ses
une extension de taffetas que c'est un
oui mais je connais taffetas mais pour
l'instant pour l'instant on ne sait pas
encore ce qu'il ya dedans véritablement
non la démocratisation les négociations
restent secrètes par contre la seule
chose qu'on est tout on est à peu près
certain c'est que ça va être fait
pourquoi les entreprises est encore plus
de marge de manoeuvre
mais toutes les entreprises qui font
appel à des grands cabinets les
accenture et c'est
au fond que que ce que les lois locales
permettent tout est clean tout est légal
ce que le luxembourg a fait c'est légal
c'est totalement indéfendable d'un point
de vue moral mais c'est parfaitement
légal l'irlande qui n'impose pas ou très
peu les profits de facebook apple etc
c'est tout à fait légal c'est-à-dire que
qu'une autre petite américaine fait
transiter des flux de capitaux par
l'irlande où ils ne sont pas taxés et
l'irlande ne taxe pas non plus parce que
la décision de faire mouvementée les
capitaux en irlande a été prise aux
états unis donc c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi c'est personne et tout ça tout ça
c'est parfaitement légal donc le jour où
on s'attaque à ça effectivement on
avance mais imaginez quelle unanimité on
va réussir à réunir entre
multinationales pour accepter de faire
taxer de façon on va peut-être plus
harmonieuse olivier
oui j'ai envie de revenir ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure donc chargé un peu
avec avec retard sur des propos
peut-être un peu un peu généraux mais
en général quand on regarde les modes
d'organisation société une grille
d'analysé intéressante et regarder
comment il s'organise au niveau de la
liberté et au niveau de l'égalité
on a vu un modèle de société qui était
basée sur l'égalité
quel est très très loin faire faillite
après 70 ans dans les années 80
évidemment le modèle modèle communiste
qui ne marchaient pas même s'il y avait
une vraie égalité dans la misère pour un
port tout le monde le goulag pour tous
quelque part pour étendre un tas modèle
vraiment d'égalité bon
l'impression que cette impression que
j'ai ce qui est pas trés pas très pas
très optimiste mais qu'on assiste à une
fuite d'un modèle qui est basée sur une
liberté absolue
qui tire ses racines déjà dans les
années 60 une forme de l'impression
qu'après après la guerre après que la
société sclérosée on a vu la liberté ce
qui est anormal et qu'on a un niveau un
peu pathologique qui fait que la liberté
devient devient absolue et écrase tout
et c'est ce qu'on vit un évidemment si
je veux la liberté bajot plus de
réglementation bancaire par exemple je
veux faire ce que je veux je mets les
mes activités
je veux dire ce que je veux peu importe
les conséquences
je veux je vais aller m'occuper de ce
qui se passe dans tel et tel pays mais
parce que je considère comme une valeur
supérieure en tout cas un modèle comme
ça dix paires d'hyper liberté et qui au
final quand on le tire donne évidemment
un mode et libéra qui prospère mais
aussi un individualisme spécialement
qu'est ce qui est plus
libérale que l'individualisme forcené
dont je m'occupe de bapaume et peu
importe de ce qui se passe et ce qui est
un peu désespérant c'est ça chauffe qui
marque aussi notre société avec les
conséquences dont on parlait tout à
l'heure olive étudier tout à l'heure le
système a besoin de soupape quelque part
avec les paradis fiscaux mais enfin dans
la fin des années 40 aux etats unis le
taux d'imposition sur le revenu et à
plus de 90 % le taux marginal quand
reagan thatcher arrive au pouvoir fin
des années 70 fin des 70 le taux
marginal sur le revenu aux états unis et
en angleterre il est de 70% 70%
aujourd'hui en france il est 45 à peu
près donc on voit qu'on est déjà très
loin de ce qui était perçu comme la
norme de solidarité minimale pendant les
trente glorieuses voit qu'aujourd'hui on
a l'impression avait passé à 46 c'est le
communisme qui arrive et ce quelque part
ça justifierait presque de la fraude
tout ça donc ça montre bien qu'il ya un
problème profond et finalement si
j'essaie contraintes là bas je veux voir
des politiques aussi qu'ils vont pas me
chatouiller là dessus un politique qui
va me parler d'intérêt général
il va pas il n'ya pas avoir une audience
très forte peut-être que ça aussi ça
joue dans ce qu'on vit actuellement
alors bien sûr que le professionnalisme
un impact mais enfin après toutes les
années 60 ans n'avait aucune classe
politique était assez professionnaliser
s'empêcher pas d'avoir d'avoir des
politiques qui étaient des vrais chefs
d'état et qui nous tiraient à séo
n'avait d'ailleurs pas besoin de se
mettre à 28 pays européens pour avoir
une france qui est qui illumine qui les
mine vraiment la planète entière donc ça
c'est un axe de réflexion tout ça pousse
à au fond une société
on vous parlait tout à l'heure sur le
grès dit quoi ces dix mois combien tu
gagnes je te dirai si tu as réussi ta
vie quoi c'est c'est ça avoir macron qui
nous dira le frac est plutôt jeune qui a
envie d'être milliardaire s'il y en
avait deux trois qui ont envie d'être
profond dans lieu ça peut nous éviter
des petits problèmes aussi dans les
instants qui viennent ça on voit qu'on
les trouve pas donc tout ça c'était il
ya un côté un peu un peu déprimant j'ai
pas j'ai pas de réponse et je joue un
bon tout ce qui est dit est juste il
vient et fort à l'heure actuelle à
travers paul volcker pour revenir à ce
qu'ils ont été les valeurs fondamentales
du métier de banquier qui est ce que je
connais est pratiqué pendant un
demi-siècle des ses valeurs c'était
connais ton client agi dans l'intérêt à
long terme de ton client et pense à ce
qu'il est bon pour
la communauté à laquelle tu appartiens
des clients à société ton pays bon nous
étions il ya 45 ans ayant travaillé avec
les américains jugés spécifiquement sur
la façon dont nous mettions en pratique
ses valeurs bon alors
depuis on a dérivé on a dérivé
massivement et la réalité c'est que un
homme paul
r essaye de revenir aux fondamentaux
il essaye de dire aux banques
américaines
le gouvernement vous a autorisé à voir 3
% de fonds propres c'est à dire 3 3 2
euros de fonds propres 97 de crédit je
vous recommande d'arriver à 7% il leur
dit
de haut que les conseils
d'administration devraient arrêter de
ddd par bonus de 5 10 15 millions
d'euros de dollars à leurs dirigeants il
leur dit vous n'auriez pas le droit vous
ne devriez pas avoir plus de 3 % de
votre bilan pour a utilisés dans les
opérations spéculatives
mon inquiétude pour l'avenir des états
unis c'est que ces recommandations de
base et de valeurs en ce moment ne sont
pas entendues suffisamment aux états
unis et partout ailleurs philippe la
réglementation volcker
écoutez c'est simplement revenir sur ce
qui s'est fait de 96 97 98 pendant que
bill clinton était occupé à se débattre
avec le monicagate
messieurs robin robin à l'époque
secrétaire d'état au trésor leur en
summer et alan greenspan ont mis
carrément on refondu complètement
les règles de séparation des activités
de banque d'affaires et de banque
commerciale et de dépôt on est revenu on
a annulé les décisions prises en
33 ou 34
donc qui permettait effectivement de
sécuriser une partie
la plus la partie en fait dépôts des
clients et le côté la banque s'il avait
envie de shilin peu sur les marchés
elles le faisaient en fonction des fonds
propres de la division banque d'affaires
donc
bill clinton
ja steagall act glass steagall act donc
enterrée
bill clinton a complètement laissé faire
le pas le congrès américain a aussi à a
laissé faire et on en est donc arrivé à
des banques qui peuvent créer sans
limites de la monnaie avec le building
neglect de la fed qui a dit toute
demande de crédit que vous me souhaiter
je vous donne l'argent
à vous de voir si vos clients sont ou
non solvables mais moi
fed je ne surveille que les banques qui
sont sous mon radar et en ce qui
concerne la crise des subprimes ce sont
des officines qui plaçait des prêts et
qui ensuite
arriver à la banque en disant voilà j'ai
une pile de dossiers de gens qui
voudraient bien un crédit laissé là bas
c'est la banque qui à ce moment-là
gérait le dossier et
volumes de produits dérivés cette année
c'est combien alors c'est une pincée
c'est un autre domaine on est revenu je
pense à 750 mille milliards de dérivés
dont 70% sont des dérivés de crédit
50 millions de milliards non non on
arrivait à un million c'est à dire qu'on
va arriver on va on va arriver on va
arriver un jour un million de milliards
parce qu'avec l'argent que la bce va
mettre sur le sur la table effectivement
la courbe si on la prolonger
raisonnablement on arrivera au million
de milliards à la fin 2004 ça c'est pour
les nox c'est pour l'anecdote les
chiffres ne veulent plus rien dire alors
après la phase de dérégulation
clintonienne ensuite la phase bouche yen
où on a décidé que les riches ne
paierait plus ou quasiment plus d'impôts
ni au titre de des revenus ni surtout au
titre des plus values si finalement on
institue aux états unis un taux
d'imposition de 15 % puisque 95% des
revenus des plus riches proviennent des
revenus de valeurs mobilières donc ça
c'était la deuxième étape se bouge
tienne la troisième étape laquelle on
assiste maintenant est celle de
l'évasion fiscale de l'optimisation
fiscale massive et où les entreprises
contrairement à ce qui se passait
la tête que vous évoquez c'est à dire
qu'on était jugée sur quelque part son
patriotisme aujourd'hui une banque
internationale
multinationale est là elle a un terrain
de jeu qui est la planète entière et
vous avez ubs ou credit suisse qui
viennent chasser le millionnaire ou le
milliardaire aux états unis pour lui
provoque poli proposer des solutions
d'optimisation fiscale donc les banques
aujourd'hui sont globales et bien sûr
elles ont une vision globale de la
fiscalité et la vision globale de la
fiscalité c'est qu'en mélangeant toutes
les ficelles on arrive à réduire le taux
d'imposition en dessous de pdg de
terreur en dessous de 7 à 8 en moyenne
pour dire que la situation est pire que
ce que vous dites parce que là la fin
d'un briseur essaye de remettre un peu
de discipline et des tic mais il s'est
créé à côté des banques commerciales
une industrie financière qui représente
autant que le pnb américain 23 trillions
23 mille milliards de dollars qu'on
appelle la banque de l'ombre le géo de
londres ou de londres l'once à ce massif
surperficie londres
on est amis d'hervé écrit la banque de
londres qui représente autant que le pnb
américain et qui est florissant et
contrôlé par personne donc le risque
bancaire américain pur les banques
qui n'ont pas failli sam elliott et le
risque financier américain c'est à mon
avis détériorer projet c'est le même
c'est à dire qu'en fait le shadow
banking il est fait par qui il est fait
par goldman sachs part c'est bien tout
par jp par par tout le monde donc cesser
c'est une émanation des banques donc de
toutes façons au système le système
bancaire américain il est il est
toujours plus en risque mais exactement
comme c'est ça qui est fascinant c'est à
dire que il ya il ya 2008 qui arrive qui
est un coup de massue
sur le risque bancaire qui aurait dû
ouvrir les yeux aux
dirigeants et au système bancaire est en
fait pas du tout c'est à dire qu'on se
retrouve six ans plus tard dans une
situation qui est pire que la veille de
2008 et tout le monde a l'impression que
tout va bien parce que évidemment on
vous vend des stress tests ridicule on
vous vend on vous fait du marketing on
vous dit tous les jours que la bnp c'est
bien que on a les meilleures banques
possible que on a absolument aucun
risque nulle part or c'est faux on a
plus de risques qu'avant et donc
est ce que vous voyez sur le monsieur
wolker fait tout ce qu'il peut mais il a
déjà fait tout ce qu'il peut tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient déjà d'aider la fin de
la crise de 2008 va pas mettre des
rideaux des neuf dès 2009 il est arrivé
en disant qu'il fallait refaire un à six
goals un contrat mais personne ne
l'écoutent a le le sait ça a été ça a
été très probablement le meilleur
banquier central qui ait jamais eus aux
états unis mais c'est vrai qu'on préfère
regarder le body language de madame
jelen plutôt que les paroles de monsieur
wolker beaucoup plus intéressant mary j
olivier
non en effet je partage cette vision
assez à faire quelque chose assez
désespérant de voir qu'on est passé
finalement à côté du gouffre qu'on a pas
2008 on a joué à la roulette russe en
fait on a mis une balle s'est tournée
cette on a tiré et puis maintenant ils
viennent vous dire très bien vous êtes
rustre regarder on a joué ça a bien
marché on recommence tout assez ça mais
maintenant au moins cinq balles
il ya pas de leçons ont été tirées moi
je pense qu'il ya pleine leçon qui ont
été tirés les banques et se sont dit
tiens
si un débat l'état va venir ou alors la
banque centrale maintenant qu'on la
maîtrise bien bas va faire tourner
éventuellement elle planche à billets
pour nous refinancer c'est vraiment je
répète assez c'est un modèle de fraude
d'une analyse est ce ce truc là qu'ils
auraient dû réagir des gouvernements bon
gouvernement aux états unis on sait bien
qu'il est dans les mains des banquiers
tels sont vous prenez les directeurs les
ministres de l'économie ou des finances
aux états unis la plupart du temps c'est
l'ancien pdg de goldman sachs house et
futur p dg de goldman sachs chez nous on
a mis à tien emmanuel macron ça c'est
des symboles qui sont qui sont qui sont
assez étonnants géré on voit qu'on a des
gens propres tous respectables n'accuse
pas dire ils sont ils sont dans leur
système je pense même parfois de son
avis cette déclaration du commerce axa
qui se prend quelque part il divo
gesvres je vois la gloire de dieu fâché
je fais de bourdieu en gros et je pense
qu'ils pensent et ce ne sont pas une
espèce de folie des grandeurs comme ça
c'est la cocaïne oui je peux peut-être
mais en tout cas avec des conséquences
qu'ils auraient suffi sérieusement les
visionner sur des sur des montants qui
sont qui sont qui sont gigantesques
walter du montant des produits dérivés
faut savoir en moyenne le risque maximal
est d'à peu près 10% du montant
notionnel que vous citez tout à l'heure
quand on voit que ça fait un risque et
qui au moins du niveau du pib mondial
sur les dix fois le pib mondial recule à
un jeu toujours coupées et je vais vous
demander votre avis sur le traitement
médiatique de ce type d'information donc
nous nous on est issu des réseaux en
issus de l'internet sont des écoutes les
gens on est vraiment plugin
d'intelligence collaborative on a
vraiment des remontées d'informations de
toutes parts et du globe entier donc le
traitement médiatique qu'il faudrait
avoir votre avis vous qui parcourt et de
temps en temps des plateaux télé de
donnez moi votre avis c'est à dire que
est-ce que vous pensez que les
journalistes sont à la hauteur du
problème qu'on va être obligé
d'affronter est ce que pour vous c'est
une forfaiture donc pas une forfaiture
est ce que repensé pour être trivial et
un peu vulgaire ils ont un pois chiche
dans le crabe ou d'un responsable de
rédaction qui qui est tenu un petit peu
par
les couilles parce que son patron
travaille dans la finance ou à des
intérêts dedans donc là là c'est une
question qui paraît un peu un peu
génériques et vous vous en pensez quoi
c'est bien
qu'ils commencent jeudi dès que
le traitement médiatique
égale le traitement politique nous
n'avons mené en politique ni dans les
médias un nombre suffisant de
responsables de terrain qui comprennent
ces mécanismes quand on dit comme on
vient de dire que le seul à de la banque
de l'ombre c'est la même chose que la
bande tout court c'est inexact
je vous dis pas ce que je suis dans la
banque de long mais je vais financer ces
des milliardaires des gens qui ont 5 10
30 milliards de dollars à leur
disposition qui travaille donc avec des
entités sans passer par les banques et
ça c'est très compliqué à gérer donc je
dis que d'abord c'est un sujet qui
évolue tout le temps ensuite c'est un
sujet technique complexe enfin les
vraies informations sont détenues par
les banques centrales qui ne les diffuse
très peu et ça demande de fouiller en
profondeur ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
des banques et dans le financier mondial
c'est c'est un appel aux hackers que
vous faites là
oui d'accord gégé est un juste une
question fait que pour moi avec tous ces
milliardaires comment ça se fait qu'il y
en a pas un qui se transforme un petit
peu en batman 1 pourquoi il n'ya pas un
milliardaire qui décide un petit peu de
de rendre justice blanc c'était sa
philosophie serait jamais devenu
milliardaire enfants
moi je
remet quand même le truction tels que je
suis absolument désolé mais il y avait
il ya quand même une bonne partie du
shadow banking c'est les banques qu'il
organise avec run avec des trucs qui
sont basés dans des paradis fiscaux et
qui sont des montages alors je veux bien
qu'à l'origine vous ayez un milliardaire
sauf que le milliardaire il appelle son
pote de chez goldman sachs et qui
montrent une petite surprise mais
d'accord et donc
et quelque part si goldman sachs fait
partie des émetteurs de ces produits ex
paiera le risque il est bien porté par
la banque à un moment ou un autre donc
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il n'y ait pas
tellement de de séparation entre entre
les banques et le rsa on imagine bien
sûr ça doit être une fonction de
direction après sur les médias sur les
médias je serais assez d'accord avec
avec un vrai il ya vrai souci c'est que
c'est pas tellement les médias
finalement aux journalistes il est là
pour pour animer un débat autres ce qui
est ce qui est catastrophique c'est les
soi disant experts qu'on voit défiler
les monsieur pigasse attali etc qui
viennent vous dire des bêtises mais qui
sont ces têtes ccdh un niveau tellement
bas que c'est c'est juste catastrophique
or ces gens-là conseil les politiques en
permanence alain minc mais attali
dominique strauss kahn tout ça c'est des
gens qui en permanence conseil des états
conseil des politiques alors que ils ont
un petit pois dans la tête alors on a
franchement on a la chance d'avoir
aujourd'hui hervé de carmoy qui a un
pied aussi dans la commission
trilatérale et qui est censé dire que
conseiller les dirigeants
hervé qu'est ce que fait la commission
mise à part se réunir sans nous inviter
la commission trilatérale a dès
l'origine elle a 35 ans d'âge créée par
david rockefeller georges bertoua et un
grand japonais pour résoudre et gérer
les tensions entre l'amérique l'europe
et je sais ça l'origine
conflit d'intérêts vous voulez
libéralisé et tous les exportations en
dollars
japonais on n'en met pas et donc on a
passé des années à trouver le moyen de
vous voulez
supprimer les contrôles bancaires aux
états unis nous on va pas faire de même
en europe vous voulez
vous avez encore des sentiments mitigés
à tonalité très négative envers les
russes nous européens on a une vue des
russes un peu différente et on pense
qu'il ya manière d matière à négociation
donc
ce que nous faisons ce que nous
discutons de nos conflits j'allais dire
lié à notre passé à notre position à nos
ressources pour en matière financière
nous sommes
séparés des états unis parce que nous
n'avons pas besoin des états unis pour
trouver des dollars on en trouve déjà à
revendre donc on a beaucoup moins besoin
d'eux on a besoin d'eux dans quoi on a
besoin d'être informé
il a les services de renseignements
bancaires et les services de
renseignement tout court entre les
européens et les états unis marche très
bien et en profondeur et limite certains
risques mais il ya des renseignements
sur des individus qui font d d d d d du
rocambolesque
financiers ce qui est la caractéristique
des dix dernières années
qu'on ne nous dit pas que nous apprenons
quand la bulle éclate
quand ma douce à aprimo soit
60 milliards un des 1 des européens et
américains à des particuliers les
américains ne nous ont à peine prévenu
donc c'est une relation de rapports de
force et notre rapport de force parce
que nous savons pas être
unifiée au point de vue politique en
europe nous sommes dans un état de
faiblesse par rapport aux états unis et
aimer la commission trilatérale vous
voulez pas la changer en commission
quadri latéral en ajoutant un peu plus
internet non non non non on a déjà
beaucoup de peine on a fait entrer la
chine et à
le nombre de différences de points de
vue entre
européens américains japonais et chinois
sur les questions de géopolitique
comment traiter la russie que faire avec
le pétrole comment éviter que des grands
pays en voie de développement du fait de
l'augmentation
du prix du dollar ne se trouve en double
difficulté grave nous avons beaucoup de
peine avec les américains ne
s'intéressent pas énormément aux
européens ils ne souhaitent pas parler
avec l'europe il aime les dialogues
individuel avec tel dirigeant avec tel
groupe mais il s'intéresse modérément à
l'europe donc notre influence sur les
états unis et moyens pourquoi parce que
nous n'avons pas d'armée mais ça il faut
quand même reconnaître que
l'élément central de la culture
américaine c'est l'armée c'est à travers
l'art mais qu'ils intègrent
toutes les populations c'est à travers
l'art mais je sais voici d'intégrer le
bon mot les acquéreurs et ben oui
désintégré ou vaporiser olivier o
philippe philippe le premier point micro
la parole que je vais rebondir
sur
la question initiale qui était et les
médias dans tout ça font-ils leur boulot
la question elle est évidemment
complexe à plusieurs niveaux d'abord
supposons que nous aurions affaire à des
journalistes honnêtes ce qui est le
moins la moindre des choses il faudrait
aussi utiliser la compétence pour
investiguer dans le domaine où on leur
demande d'aller creuser un peu or très
vite un journaliste honnête intègre et
efficace un robert par exemple il se
heurte immédiatement à semur de pas
citer l'opacité sur le clae ring qui se
fait au luxembourg l'opacité des comptes
de la fed qui ne publient plus la masse
monétaire déjà depuis cinq ou six ans
opacité totale de la fed en ce qui
concerne ses stocks d'or personne ne
peut depuis 30 ans savoir ce qu'il ya
dans les coffres à fort knox ou à new
york aucun congressman américain n'a
jamais obtenu l'autorisation d'aller
investiguer pour savoir ce qui a
vraiment dans les réserves 2
de la banque centrale américaine alors
quel journaliste pour et y parvenir
puisque même l'homme politique qui tient
le plus haut grade on va dire même le
chef du congrès américain ne peut pas
aller avec une commission denquête dire
bon voilà maintenant la fa la la fed
faut qu'elles soient transparentes il
faut qu'on sache ce qui à la banque
centrale la banque des règlements
internationaux qui la banque centrale
des banques centrales en quelque sorte
qui gère 70% des mouvements de capitaux
dans le monde de temps en temps elle
publie parce que ça fait partie des
choses qu'elle rend public elle publie
par exemple l'encours des dérives et
c'est pour ça que je peux vous citer un
chiffre de 7 5 à 750 milliards par
contre on ne sait pas exactement quel
est le risque que courent chaque banque
individuellement on sait grosso modo que
la 2e banque auraient quelque chose
comme 50 de 1000 milliards d'encours
c'est à dire 30 fois le pib de
l'allemagne on sait que quelques banques
ont des logis absolument phénoménaux non
on ne sait pas exactement en quoi
consistent ces encours nickel quel est
le risque associé donc pour un
journaliste est vachement difficile
d'aller chercher l'information parce que
les banques centrales aient même sont
totalement opaques et parce qu'il n'y a
aucun moyen politique d'obtenir de ses
banques centrales qui sont totalement
indépendantes la moindre information
donc on est mal parti la deuxième chose
les médias à qui appartient-il aux états
unis naturellement bon en la lisant plus
le plus flagrant c'est fox tv avec des
journalistes qui règne à turow comme
ceux qui prétendent qu à paris à des
zones de deux endroits où des zones
musulmanes ne peut plus aller on a
d'autres groupes comme liberty média qui
possède plusieurs journaux là on a
affaire à des gens qui comprennent bien
comment fonctionne le système enfin les
propriétaires en france qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui possède le monde 1
bah c'est un trio niel pigasse et là on
découvre aujourd'hui que l'express
l'expansion
c'est finalement patrick drahi ce qui
met à la tête son banquier d'affaires de
chez morgan stanley qui va donc prendre
la tête donc 2
de l'express expansion y 24 chaînes
d'information en temps réel donc vous
voyez quand même que l'information
aujourd'hui elle est bien sous le
contrôle de gens qui comprennent très
très bien calé au système comment il
fonctionne est ce que ces gens là vont
recruter des journalistes pitbull qui
vont aller creuser pour savoir comment
se pratiquent l'évasion fiscale en
europe comment les banques prennent des
banquiers prennent des leviers pas
possible etc il est évident que là il
faudrait vraiment croire que ces gens
ont un amour immodéré pour la
transparence et pour
l'information au sens noble du terme de
dire j'achète un groupe de presse pour
que ces gens-là fasse vraiment leur
métier et dévoile au pop comment les
choses fonctionnent vraiment allons-y
rassure toi ils étaient tous à la manif
pour la liberté d'expression en revanche
olivier
oui pour pour dire moi j'ai un
châtain vous voulez un ancien ministre
du budget mais qu'at il est donc devenu
un peu importe week end jolie phrase sur
sur notre modèle politique parce que ça
sentait le sapin non ça ne sentait pas
ça ne sentait pas le sapin un peu plus
compétents que ça quand même le
il a dit finalement en france la france
est une système politique français est
une monarchie élective
influencé par une oligarchie discrète si
on regarde c'est assez c'est assez juste
on our démocratie démocratie on sait
très bien qu'en 2017 et une fille née
vous allez avoir
un candidat du mtq on peut être candidat
du ps il y aura peut-être un marine le
pen qui assura la victoire d'un des deux
directement ce qui revient à peu près au
même donc on voit que le modèle de
sélection était assez biaisé d'ailleurs
on connaît un peu près les candidats qui
est assez désespérant en terme de retour
vers le futur
donc voilà on a un vrai problème déjà
évité à démocratique à ceux à ce moment
là en plus avec un total heures philippe
pas parler de montée des extrêmes dans
ce qu'on vive enfin des extrêmes on y
est aussi déjà quand on s'assoit sur le
référendum de 2005 faut être sacrément
extrémistes pour faire ça quand on
dérégule tout le système bancaire est-ce
que tout à l'heure on ou philippe tu
parlais du un docte hinton qui en 99
avait des réguler les banques en en
supprimant le laisser faire mais
pourquoi parce que les banquiers
américains lisez aussi en partie et ça
fait 15 ans qu'ils sont des réguliers en
france
ah oui la france est le premier pays au
monde à avoir du recul et ses banques
1984 enfin du de la loi bancaire dès
1945 donc on voit qu'on est dans des
dans des systèmes comme ça qu'ils sont
qui sont ils sont extrémistes sur plein
de points enfin on est il ya des
millions de chômeurs explique ne va
falloir travailler plus sans être payé
mon face qui m'aiment pas socialement et
délirant du point de vue économique
c'est déjà du travail il y en a pas pour
4 millions de personnes donc si vous les
payez pas il y aura personne pour
acheter ce qu'on produit on a des idées
qui sont aussi extrémistes à être amis
ce n'est pas que que d'un côté du du
champ politique et la deuxième réflexion
que kim était venu c'était une réflexion
de noam chomsky qui travaille beaucoup
sur les modèles de propagande et qui
disait que la propagande et aux
démocraties c'est que la matraque et aux
dictatures ou bien évidemment en
dictature pour elle pas trop de
questions ce qui n'est pas d'accord en
fait mais tape dessus en démocratie
on se mit démocratie dans lequel on
situation dans laquelle on est en tout
cas en non démocratie libérale on
pourrait dire aussi ce qui est très
heureusement très différent d'une
dictature il va falloir arriver à
façonner l'opinion publique pour que les
gens aux états unis les 90% de la
population qui se font tondre il faut
qu'il accepte donc somme toute ça se
fait pas tout seul alors bien sûr il ya
aucun complot un faux-pas pas rentrer
dans ces dans ces phases là mais comme
le disait philippe il ya un espèce de
d'entre eux soit dans des médias qui
sont sains qui sont extrêmement limitées
en nombre enfin comme on dit c'est quand
même fou enfin tous nos médias sont la
propriété de cinq ou six milliardaires
opus est milliardaire il s'affaire si
vraiment il investit dans des boîtes qui
marche tel investissent tous latin des
bottes qui marche pas tu es faut
vraiment avoir un amour de l'information
qui est quand même à saluer et puis cet
étonnant une fois que qu'ils ont ces
médias les médias sont prêts vachement
moins critique sur sur le système qui
permet justement à des milliardaires
d'acheter d'acheter
le système le système démocratique voilà
donc au final on a on a une forme de
cloisonnement une forme de plutocratie
qui
1,6 à mon avis ce masque derrière une
pseudo une seule démocratie finalement
c'est poilant je sais pour savoir en
2017 si on aura comme communiste de
l'économie encore françois baroin ou
emmanuel macron dire c'est ça la
différence politique oui on peut choisir
entre les deux je rappelle françois
baroin segal ump je précise parce que
sinon je sais pas trop il s'est passé
pas mal qu'on pourrait le croire
donc c'est assez c'est assez désespérant
et au final on a en effet des
journalistes qui sont qui ont aussi
beaucoup changé sociologiquement en est
loin du modèle journalistique des années
70 c'était quoi c'était
moment quelqu'un qui avait un niveau
assez assez moyen mais qui était parent
ou d'heures qui en voulait qu'ils
buvaient et hemingway machin gens qui
allaient croiser aujourd'hui on a
quelqu'un qui avait six possibles fait
une une science po en province et puis
qui se dit tiens je vais aller là dedans
surtout pas trop faire de vagues ce que
j'en fais en plus la hiérarchie me fait
savoir que c'est pas très bien
puisqu'elles sont les hiérarchies passe
son temps au siècle
et dans un entre soi qui est vraiment
qui est vraiment très étonnant c'est que
la question c'est pourquoi finalement se
laisse faire pourquoi on accepte d'avoir
aussi peu de même sur la partie
information on pourrait exiger des
choses plus plus plus offensive mais on
arrive à une situation qui est quand
même assez paradoxal on à la génération
vraiment du peuple de l'histoire la
mieux éduquée bonté divine il ya quand
même le proportion qui a fait des études
par rapport à il ya 50 ou 100 ans où on
avait des paysans inculte
on arrive à avoir une population
vachement éduqués qui finalement un
système politique qui est désespérant
enfin je rappelle qu'il ya un siècle il
y avait du victor hugo du lamartine du
jaurès de clemenceau à l'assemblée il
n'était pas forcément représentatif de
l'ensemble l'assemblée des peuples en
tout cas au moins ils étaient là
aujourd'hui nadine morano harlem désir
il ya un vrai sujet aussi pourquoi on en
arrive là parce que mine de rien
effectivement ça fait rigoler mais et
c'est quand même eux qui pilote le
système vial françois hollande pilote la
france et pour le coup dans un système
qui est sans doute le système en france
où président le plus de pouvoir envoie
qui décide de tout on voit qu'on a
reconstitué finalement louis 15 ou 20
lits bosse quand il a envie quand il n'a
pas envie on se demande avec qui il est
voilà enfin c'est quand même des
questions qui sont qu'ils sont beaux
jours vous nous avez rhabiller les
politiques et les médias pour l'hiver
c'est très bien maintenant on va voir en
ce moment le rêve en ce moment il va pas
on va passer aux solutions
je vais vous demander à chacun on va
vous demander à chacun
d'essayer de proposer des solutions on
commence par hervé a juste avant a juste
avant hervé te lancer de vous lancer là
dessus
je voudrais autant les investissements
aux etats-unis où nous sommes des
les investissements aux etats unis bon
alors il ya un domaine où ça décroît
massivement qui est celui de
l'innovation
l'innovation aux états unis depuis huit
ans n'est pas c'est dans le privé de 100
milliards de dollars à 15 milliards de
dollars l'année dernière
l'innovation financé par le public ad
était bien là 100 milliards il ya huit
ans sur 50 milliards aujourd'hui donc on
peut dire que l'investissement mais ce
donc
c'est de ce point de vue là c'est
préoccupant
jamais il n'y a eu autant d'argent
disponible se trouvant aux états unis
dont différents fonds pour investir et
là le contraste est saisissant
nous avons des responsables financiers
d'affaires qui sont assis sur des
fortunes qui vont de 5 à 100 milliards
de dollars et qui sont assis dessus et
qui - était une réunion d'entre eux et
il y en a qui parlait en france au
xviiie siècle de leurs quartiers de
noblesse eux parlent leurs quartiers de
noblesse et dans quelle tranche de
dizaines de milliards ils se trouvent et
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
continuer à accumuler donc nous avons là
une
un ralentissement de l'investissement le
plus difficile l'investissement
immobilier reprend parce que c'est la
base c'est comme ça qu'on attire toute
cette population qui vient émigré aux
états unis ont des facilités colossal
pour emprunter par crédit hypothécaire
on leur fait toute série de facilités et
on leur fait rêver que dans trente ans
l'appartement qu'ils ont ou la maison
qu'ils ont achetée pour 150 milles de là
en vaudra façon bill donc ralentissement
de l'investissement difficile
investissements massifs des grandes
unités américaines dans le monde entier
financiarisation à l'extrême
juste avant de passer à la recherche de
solutions si on en trouve
j'aimerais juste avoir une petite
vulgarisation pour
monsieur tout le monde quand on parle de
ma ce mario draghi donc gouverneurs de
la bce qui parle d' injecter 1000
milliards ce qui représente un peu près
jusqu'en 2016 quoi ces deux milliards
par jour quelque chose comme ça c'est 60
milliards par mois soit 2 millions marge
de remonter bon donc là concrètement
hormis l'inflation
qu'est ce que ça va représenter pour le
pékin lambda rien
ou très peu parce que le pékin lambda
seraient impactés si les banques qui
vont prendre cet argent ou le recevoir
et est disposée à
l'investir et pourquoi est ce que les
banques investissent moins mais je vous
pose la question pour une raison qu'il
ya trois raisons la première c'est que
pour investir et créer des emplois il
faut des entrepreneurs ils foutent le
camp oui par centaines rien qu'en
belgique il y à 500 entrepreneurs
français qui sont arrivés depuis trois
ans
envoyez les nous renvoyer les deux
renvoyer les nous mêmes étaient dans un
bus les
autocars et vous ne guérirez dacron je
suis tout à fait prêt à vous aider mais
je peux pas le faire tout ça bon il y en
a plus encore qui sont partis aux états
unis en angleterre et quelques-uns en
suisse bon donc voilà le le point qui
qui qui qui achoppe le plus
ok
vous parliez ce matin de 40 milliards
pas de 40 milliards que la france devra
rembourser au pays la dette de la dette
grecque
oui ça c'est c'est ce qu' elle a une
tête lui penser que la grèce va
rembourser à la france 40 milliards ça
me paraît un optimisme alors là c'est le
banquier qui vous parle veut dire que
c'est un homme gris misme délirant ne
peuvent pas il faudrait qu'ils y
repenser leur économique il qu'il y ait
des abandons de créances qui vient tout
ça n'est tout le monde luttent pour
qu'il n'y ait pas tout ça donc la
solution pour la grèce je ne l'est pas
tenez monsieur pigasse la harpe il a dit
il a dit il ne faut pas remboursé de
toute façon ça n'a aucune conséquence
alors donc monsieur pigasse à la
solution vous ne remboursez pas la
personne qui vous a prêté de l'argent et
ça n'a aucune conséquence donc sachez le
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui nous écoutent
peuvent aller voir leur banquier de
lazard je dois je vais à 2 millions de
monsieur py des as a dit que ça n'avait
aucune conséquence parce que c'était
dans votre bilan donc je me permettrai
de ne pas vous rembourser tout va bien
monsieur pigasse a toujours une solution
bonne solution et chad l'a fait valser
regrette et ses regrets qui est
extrêmement
stressante pour l'industrie financière
pour les gouvernements rendez vous
compte
compte tenu de son degré de séniorité si
on faisait un haircut de 50% sur la
dette grecque ça pourrait coûter au
final environ
20 milliards
peut-être 27 28 à l'allemagne il ya
quelques jours la banque centrale
annonce qu'elle va injecter dans 60
milliards par mois pendant pendant
jusqu'au mois de septembre 2016 l'orgie
via le port de reprenant c'est pour rire
parce qu'au départ et n'a qui ont pensé
que c'était une île 4080 milliards qui
seraient injectés allanon mois de
septembre 2016 inclus harbig ça fait pas
1060 ça fait 1140 60 milliards de mieux
mais ces 60 milliards de mieux ils sont
arrivés comme ça plus c'est cadeau voilà
on peut éteindre la dette grecque du
jour au lendemain c'est ses 60 milliards
de plus que la bce a mis sur le tapis ça
s arrête à la dette grecque complètement
enfin on tentera de se faire des noeuds
aux neurones en ce moment avec avec une
histoire qui devrait même pas posé de
question pourquoi est ce que on devrait
continuer de faire croire que la gueule
à la dette grecque sera remboursé on
sait bien depuis le départ qu'elle ne le
sera jamais et moi j'ai un exemple dans
l'histoire qui est merveilleux qui était
à la faillite de l'eau au début du
xviiie siècle je pense était entre 1700
1715 1720 alors on a créé de la monnaie
beaucoup beaucoup de monnaie dont
l'essentiel était en fait les titres de
la compagnie des indes et 7 cas où cette
compagnie des indes et mettait de la
monnaie sur de la richesse future a créé
richesse qui évidemment n'est jamais
arrivé sur tout cas pas ça on a largué
la louisiane on a revendu mais au départ
on a fait croire qu'il y aurait à la
sortie
de l'argent qui permettrait de
rembourser de faire face à la monnaie
créée en fait le dit c'était suivant
vous amenez votre or vos pièces d'argent
et on vous donne de la monnaie papier
sur de la richesse future à venir le
jour où
le système de l'eau fait faillite
s'écroulent
là on a eu très très chaud parce que il
ya eu des morts à rue quincampoix ça à
ça cartonnait devant la banque de
monsieur law ça chauffait et qu'est ce
qu'on a décidé ce jour là on a décidé à
un truc incroyable inconcevable à notre
époque on a décidé de rembourser les
pauvres ce qui avait amené quelques
pièces d'or et qui à maman se sont cru
riche et puis d'un seul coup qui ont
failli ne plus rien à voir on a
remboursé les pauvres si jamais on avait
fait ça avec la grèce dès 2010 mais il y
aurait plus de soucis d'aucune sorte on
aurait simplement fait jouer une sorte
de solidarité ou une sorte de sens de la
réalité sociale et on aurait
complètement éteint la dette grecque
comme on a remboursé les pauvres les
grecs aujourd'hui je roule je joue ce
rôle dépendre de 18 de
1720 et les portugais et des portugais
et c'est donc ce canyon donc là on est
de nouveau on est de nouveau dans ce
principe moral
de l'égoïsme de chacun pour soi de
l'individualisme je coupe hélas ça n'a
rien à voir c'est d'avoir un hacker
lucidité hervé vont parier de vos
réunions avec les ubrich les ultra
riches alors ce sens sans briser le
secret des dieux est-ce qu'ils
s'organisent et est-ce qu'ils sont un
petit peu l'histoire se répéter avec les
révoltes avec des gens avec des fourches
en bas de chez eux s qui esquisse
aménage un plan b loin de tout le monde
avec une milice privée ou de choses
comme ça et des pièces d'or et les
pièces dans la réalité de ces gens-là ce
qu'ils sont à l'abri
pour
les américains jamais un gouvernement
américain ne va dire à quelqu'un vous
avez 47 milliards de dollars
dans différents paradis fiscaux vous les
avez déclaré et voulait conserver
nous vous nous en donner une partie pour
aider les autres je ne le crois pas je
ne crois pas qu'il y ait à l'heure
actuelle on a parlé tout à l'heure
de
l'égalité on a parlé de la liberté cette
croissance de la liberté il n'y a pas de
par le monde que traitent
d'une façon microscopique d'augmentation
de la fraternité et ça avec les plus
démunis ce sentiment est très faible et
n'intéresse pas les américains c'est
contraire ils ont beaucoup de dons ils
ont un dynamisme vente astique qui
veulent créer de l'argent et y laisse
aux individus le soin d'en donner selon
leurs préférences moi ma meilleure amie
est une femme qui a 150 millions de
dollars qui depuis quinze ans consacre
aux siens cette somme aux chiens malades
donc voilà c'est sa liberté c'est son
argent le droit d'en faire ce qu'il faut
mais là l'idée de de solidarité
fraternité est très faible donc je pense
que là nous n'avons pas beaucoup
d'espoir car en fait ma question c'est
je me suis mal exprimé de ma question
portait sur le fait est que la peur
d'une révolte sociale à grande échelle
les anime et est-ce qu'il prépare un
plan b pour une exfiltration d'une pose
cette question quelque chose qui m'a qui
m'a beaucoup étonné c'est la police
privée de google
payés par google dans en californie à
une consigne qui est un plan
d'évacuation des salariés
spécifique 1 à google donc si une
révolte se passe là bas la police a pour
ordre d'évacuer le personnel de google
donc pas question était est ce que la
peur commence à
arriver c'était évident qu'ils prennent
tous des mesures de quel type ils ont
leurs polices personnel ils ont leur
avion personnel il vit peuvent partir en
quelques heures pour le canada qui est
infiniment
plus laxistes dans tous ces domaines que
l'eau d'autres pays
bien sûr d'accord on passe aux solutions
oui j'aurais juste aimé faire un petit
point sur la grèce le parti socialise
art et justement tu connais pas de la
grèce il ya quelques instants avec la
partie bête
le fait que deux des responsables de la
partie économique
partage londres à la city rassurer les
marchés en expliquant que
ce qui avant étaient des promesses de ne
pas rembourser
niveau des des promesses électorales
finalement ils vont quand même rassuré
les marchés derrière en disant non ça va
bien se passer parce que c'est une
arnaque en face c'est que c'est hollande
qui dit exactement des l'on hissé la
finance et qui pèsera à londres juste
après pour vendre sa soupe c'est du
marketing celle uniquement du marketing
donc voilà ils ont ils ont dit à rose
sur sur le rang sur on ne remboursera
pas la dette est le première visite qui
fonce et aux banquiers de londres donc
baisser ce qui est étonnant c'est que
c'est que ça vous surprennent
mais voilà à face et du marketing c'est
le principe de ma pote crassus très
succinctement des solutions on commence
par philippe philippe est ce qu'on
réinvente le freedom braz hors
jeu je pense que l'amérique reste
aujourd'hui le pays leader
donc je vais faire une évocation à
laquelle évidemment je n'accorde
strictement
aucun crédit dans le sens où je sais aps
suis convaincu que ça ne se réalisera
jamais mais je donne la parole à barack
obama
qui a fait une proposition tout
récemment début février
qui était de dire aux multinationales
américaines vous qu'il y avait 150 200
filiales dans des paradis fiscaux bon je
sais peu ou prou ce que vous avez
délocaliser comme profit
sa rivale mesurer 1 néanmoins et moi je
vous propose un deal alors soit
tout ce que vous avez à l'étranger que
j'ai estimé par recoupement et ses jeux
le taxent à 14 pourtant vous allez
continuer bas à
déplacer votre argent entre dubaï
singapour le luxembourg
l'irlande est tout autre paradis fiscal
qui vous convient mais je vous prends
quand même 14 % force et herman voilà ou
autre deal
vous rapatrier tous ses profits
colossaux un bon apple c'est 180
milliards
facebook va être dans les trente enfin
il ya des sommes colossales à rapatrier
et je vous fait quelque part une sorte
de package
2-2
d'amnisty fiscale en quelque sorte vous
ramenez votre argent aux états unis et
je vous taxe ça à 19%
et ensuite et bien ensuite vous êtes
tranquille aux états unis on va trouver
d'autres arrangements mais ce que je
retiens surtout dans cette proportion de
14% ou de 19% que propose obama c'est de
se dire que finalement est-ce que la
fiscalité acceptable à l'échelle
planétaire se situerait pas justement
entre ces quatorze essais 19% parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec un taux d'imposition
de 8% en moyenne des multinationales du
snp 500 ou de l'eurofirst où l'euro
stoxx 600 on s'aperçoit qu'il ya aucun
état qui peut vivre
les états seront privés de ressources
donc tout est à vivre en fait au dessus
de leurs moyens non pas parce qu'ils
font plus de folie qui a sept ou huit
ans mais simplement parce que depuis
sept ou huit ans depuis qu'on a
réinjecté de l'argent dans le système et
que les entreprises se sont reconstitués
des trésoreries des capacités
bénéficiaires extraordinaire eh bien on
voit que les ailes que les
multinationales ont complètement
externaliser leurs bénéfices et ne
payent plus d'impôts dans les pays donc
est-ce qu donc homogénéisation des
systèmes mobilisation de la fiscalité
vais quand même 14 % c'est quand même
juste deux fois aujourd'hui ce que
paient les entreprises mais avec ses 14
pourtant il ya plus de déficits nulle
part et on réduit les 50 millions de
personnes au food stamps on les réduit
des deux tiers très rapidement par
exemple olivier delamarche alors cela je
pense que s'il a proposé ça c'est qui
sait que ça va pas passer puisque les
villages a
toujours gratuit et c'est en fait ça ne
sert pas à grand chose
en plus soyez sûrs que les entreprises
vont pouvoir détourner la chose en
rachetant leurs propres actions et donc
c'est pas très compliqué de de passer à
côté
je vais rebondir d'ailleurs sur ce que
disait hervé yahi il ya quelques il ya
quelques minutes à propos de
l'investissement et c'est ça qui est
gravissime parce que c'est celle à venir
aujourd'hui les entreprises
n'investissent plus la seule chose dans
lesquelles elles investissent et leurs
propres actions parce que on leur donne
de l'argent gratuitement d'un côté et
donc il est assez facile de les placer
avec un rendement qui est trois et demi
ou quatre qui est le dividende tout
simplement donc
c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est plutôt
agréable ça fait monter les actions donc
ça enrichit le patron de la société donc
tout va bien donc enfin les principaux
actionnaires de la société et donc tout
va bien sauf que ça vous obère l'avenir
quand il ya plus d'investissements en
recherche qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
va produire demain après demain et après
après-demain et et ça je pense que tous
les pays dans tout ça ce passe à peu
près dans tous les pays alors s'est
exacerbé aux états unis parce que ils
ont ce système qui permet aux
entreprises de racheter leurs propres
titres je fasse je vais vous donner une
petite idée c'est en 2014 c'est 750
milliards de dollars quand même c'est
pas rien donc ça fait beaucoup d'argent
c'est l'équivalent du caillou de l'ac
bourges a pu quasiment le cul de la
banque du japon voilà un quantitative
easing et tout ça c'est du ces du rachat
d'actions alors d'ailleurs ça sert à
camoufler les résultats vous avez des
résultats qui sont mauvais mais si vous
diminuez le nombre d'actions évidemment
il s'avère bon donc le et ça c'est
vraiment un problème parce que c'est un
problème sur le long terme je fais donc
qu'il faudrait ans je pense qu'on peut
on pourrait on pourrait assez facilement
régler ça avec la fiscalité simplement
pousser les entreprises à investir avec
avec une fiscalité plus plus plus faible
lorsqu'elles investissent
pour l'avenir plutôt que quand elles
quand elles dépensent leur argent à
acheter vêtements leur action je pense
que là on pourrait matraquer fiscalement
et que tous allaient les dirigerait dans
le bon sens donc il ya des choses à
faire mais malheureusement qui ne sont
jamais écoutés les wolker a donné
quelques quelques pistes il faudrait en
effet séparé les bols les banques
d'affaires et les les banques
de détail il faudrait réguler un petit
peu plus là la folie financière
arrêtée
la comptabilité créatrice qui permet de
de faire apparaître des profits là où il
ya des pertes
voilà enfin et rendre et malheureusement
essayer de parce que ça j'ai des doutes
sur le fait que ça se passe il faudrait
qu'on trouve quand même quelques
politiques qu'ils soient au niveau ça
serait bien
et
malheureusement ça je pense qu'on va
avoir du mal on pourrait aussi faire
sauter les nasa serait très intéressant
parce que là vraiment c'est juste
catastrophique ce qui sort de cette
institution
donc le faire sauter non mais où les
bombarder au lsd voilà par exemple et
donc non je pense que je pense qu'il ya
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
mais arrêter aussi de vendre des
histoires
complètement complètement idiote du
genre un jour la grèce remboursera on se
fiche des eaux pas rembourser une dette
parce que c'est pas grave l'ex-star tout
ça il faut en finir il faudrait informer
les gens les éduquer de façon à ce que
quand ils mettent leur bulletin dans
l'urne ils fassent pas de bêtises et il
nous les hélices pas des des coursiers
en scooter hervé des solutions et le mot
de la fin sera réservé pour olivier
berruyer pervez qu'est ce que je retire
de cette discussion
pour la france
pour un autre pays
une chose certaine c'est qu'il faut
privilégier les entrepreneurs et ne pas
les chasser il ya des centaines sinon 15
sens entrepreneurs français qui sont
partis alors il ya une rue une
suggestion énorme de louer des bus pour
les ramener en france donc de millas
aussi je voudrais compléter cette
question pertinente
en disant que nous devons arrêter nous
français
de penser que s'enrichir c'est mauvais
nous avons fait notre une phrase d
évangile où il dit qu'il est plus
difficile
un risque d'aller au ciel ou 1 1 un
cerveau d'aller à travers le trou du
degli lui une aiguille kkk qu'un riche
d'aller au ciel oublions ça oublions jeu
cette phrase je n'aime pas les riches -
je les aime parce qu'ils créent des
emplois parce qu'ils peuvent être
généreux que je constate qu'en belgique
il y a plus de fondation en belgique que
dans toute la france index et et que
sans ça me paraît très bon la deuxième
chose que je retiens des états unis est
une expérience personnelle que je n'ai
pas mentionné que je dis en trois là
venaient brain les associés a créé il ya
15 ans une petite organisation
où tous les ans elles recrutent 7 à 8
personnes qui s'occupent directement des
immigrés chacun chacune de ces personnes
à un immigré voulu immigrés qu'elle voit
toutes les semaines ou tous les 15 jours
qu'elle est financièrement quand c'est
possible quels conseils pour pouvoir
faire des études le résultat des
centaines de milliers d'immigrés qui
arrive aux états unis ne sont pas pris
en charge seulement par l'état où les
états mais par des individus qui veulent
les aider à s'intégrer
je dirais que cette démarche de
générosité est conforme au troisième mot
de
devise nationale
liberté égalité fraternité et que si
nous prenions l'initiative de promouvoir
leur genre de comportement notre pays
serait beaucoup plus fort olivier
berruyer
oui
bah pour rebondir je pense aussi qu'il
est qu'il est important aussi de deux
peut-être remettre dans les esprits ont
constitué des plus riches de finalement
l'idée de que s'appauvrir
c'est pas forcément mal et ça l'avenir
un risque de montrer où j'aimerais
réhabiliter cette idée que perdre la
moitié de sa fortune c'est pas si grave
que ça quand on est quand on est
multimillionnaire surtout si ça si ça
permet d'aider une bonne partie de la
population
ça fait moins de soucis j'incite à
chacun de relire la jolie fable de la
fontaine le savetier de financiers qui
est très intéressante à ceux à ce niveau
là haut tu as de la boutade à la
question était finalement quelle
solution rock c'était je crois que
c'était ça moi je pense qu'il en a pas
et qu'il faut arrêter de vendre ce genre
ce genre d'idées à la population je
pense que c'est pas honnête on est dans
un système qui est en dérive totale on a
très bien fait en 2008 à quoi ça peut
amener on n'a strictement rien fait
après 2008 donc aucune raison qu'on
fasse quoi que ce soit avant le prochain
le prochain crash une qui risque d'être
assez terminal pour pour la finance on
est dans un avion
les pilotes c'est françois hollande il
n'a pas le brevet à moitié de son temps
entre potes l'hôtesse alors bon je vous
dis c'est quoi la solution alors bombe à
la solution c'est peut-être d'avoir un
groupe pilote
on est dans l'avion il n'ya pas le
pilote donc après c'est l'étape suivante
c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe alors va se
crasher
sauf qu'il ya des crashs où finalement
tout le monde survit à des kraft
personnes survivent et c'est vrai qu'il
faut peut-être dans l'étape suivante
qu'est ce qui peut se passer qu'est ce
qui peut déclencher un
un grand un grand crash financier ça
peut être des problèmes bancaires ça
peut être des problèmes géopolitiques ça
peut être syriza qui déciderait au final
ne pas rembourser la dette grecque parce
que je vous rappelle que si un jour elle
décide la veille ils promettront la main
sur le coeur qu'ils rembourseront donc
ça
on ne prévoit pas ça mais ça peut être
n'importe quoi dire c'est la beauté de
ce système ça peut être un l'immobilier
en chine qui s'écroule ça peut être un
gros problème au japon ça peut être un
tsunami ça peut être un tremblement de
terre ça peut être tout et n'importe
quoi en un système qui est extrêmement
fragile un système financier qui joue
avec des sommes et des risques qui se
comptent en dizaines de milliards de
dollars et qui n'en sont absolument pas
rattrapable parlée par les états et donc
c'est ce genre de question qu est ce qui
peut se passer pour
pour les parcs des gens ont parlé tout à
l'heure de la rue quincampoix et de la
faillite un démocrate de l'aude et des
années 1740 il faut savoir pour 80 90 %
de la population est donc à peu près
tous les gens qui nous écoutent il y
aura pas trop de problèmes sur leurs sur
leur patrimoine pourquoi parce qu'ils en
ont tellement peu au final qu'on pourra
toujours les rembourser si je prends la
dette publique française 70% de la dette
publique française est détenue par 10%
de la population et niveaux les plus
riches les 10% donc si on dit on ne
rembourse pas 70% de la dette française
90% des gens seront quant à eux
remboursés donc si vous avez moins de 10
me de moins de cinquante mille euros il
ya aucun problème il y aura toujours de
quoi vous remboursez évidemment votre
ami à 175 millions de dollars
va savoir qu'elle soit courageuse un
jour peut-être que sa banque aux
caraïbes on va lui dire que ce n'est pas
fait faillite en fait y'a plus rien
c'est ce genre de chose qui peut qui
peut qui peut rêver en tout cas mon sens
il serait intéressant de débattre plutôt
que de dire oui moi je peux vous sortir
une série de 50 mesures qui serait bien
pour 1 milliard et 600 ans elle ne se
fera pas en un système politique qui est
complètement cloisonné et un système
d'information on en a parlé qui est qui
est complètement aveugle
entre entre les imbéciles et ceux qui ne
peuvent pas parler ça plaît à peu près
100 % de l'horizon médiatique c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'on a des débats
trouvera tellement intéressant sur en
main sur internet je prends pas prendre
en l'espèce mais on voit que malgré tout
on a des gens qui cherchent de
l'information et qui arrive à la trouver
sur ce sur ce média là mais qui
malheureusement restera inconnu pour 90%
de la population est donc le matraquage
continuera sa ce genre de débat qui peut
être intéressant qu'est ce qui se passe
pour le prochain krach plutôt que de
réfléchir comme ça sur rabat qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait pour que ça arrive pas eh
ben j'ai pas été déterrés de gaulle vous
essayez de prendre l'adn vous aussi de
le cloner vous mettrez ça dans une
brebis vous voyez ce qu'ils savent mais
ces présidents et puis peut-être que il
y aura ce qu'il faudra pour comprenait
pas le problème et le problème il est
devant nous et problème il est alors je
sais pas quand il fait dans un mois il
peut dans un an peut-être dans cinq ans
si à coudre d'imprimantes magique et un
mario draghi a réussi à pas faire sauter
la bce en faisant partir les allemands
en fait pour résumer votre propre au
cccc cette incapacité à prévoir conclut
rob est
une solution de sortie ça mais on est
dans un système où quand je mets une
mondialisation que je mets un des
traités transatlantique que je mets ce
que j'appelle l'organisation de
bruxelles qui est qui est là pour
essayer de mettre tous les pays en
concurrence et on est empêché la moindre
souveraineté populaire de s'exercer
quand je mets une monnaie unique mais
quand j'en arrive là j'ai qu'une
politique possible c'est la politique de
gattaz il y en a pas d'autre cette
politique va juste conduire à une
dépression et fright foulée le système
mais il a le système pouvait pas
grand-chose pour ça ça sert à rien de
dire oh mon ennemi c'est la finance
qu'est ce qui va se passer en 2010 c'est
d'ailleurs la même chose jusqu'à ce que
ça ça disons temps fait il est là le
tout devant nous la question c'est
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ça c'est ce
qui peut peut-être intéresser les gens
ben pour pour essayer d'avoir un minimum
de risques si ça disjoncte et bien
éviter d'avoir
un des obligations grecques un des
actions de banques de ne pas mettre plus
pas cinquante mille euros dans une
banque voilà c'est le genre de truc qui
peut être intéressant au niveau des
des gens que de dire bah qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait ce serait bien si j'étais si on
avait réglé les banques assise ainsi si
les gens étaient pas cupides 6 1 c'est
sûr mais en attendant les problèmes sont
devant nous et un horizon assez assez
proche oui j'ai un tout petit mois alors
à tous petits mots d'abord je suis
aujourd'hui ça à chaque fois cette
question là ça me fait penser aux gars
qui s'est jetée du 40e étage est là au
lieu de lui dire si ça va lui demander
ça va quand il passe devant le troisième
on lui dit qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire donc tu te crache pas à trois
étages plus bas et moi j'ai quand même
tendance à dire fallait pas sauter
déjà bon parce que il n'y a pas grand
chose à faire quand il est plus qu à
trois étages il va s'écraser
lamentablement
la deuxième chose là où je j'ai juste un
petit bémol par rapport à ce qu olivier
a dit olivier dit il ya suffisamment
gros d'epargne chez les 10% les plus
riches pour payer pour tous les autres
oui s'il n'y avait que la dette mais
malheureusement on l'a leverage et cette
dette est donc aujourd'hui la personne
qui a son petit pel codevi assurance vie
etc sera reims et comme les autres pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'il y aura
pas de sous parce que si on ne prend que
les par oui les parrains correspond à la
dette oui mais qu'à la dette pas au
leveraged y ait eu donc et les produits
financiers le jour où il y aura une
perte ça sera beaucoup plus important le
jour où il y aura des faillites de
banques ça sera beaucoup plus important
que la simple dette de 2 milliards de la
france mais ce que la science est de
continuer on fait une autre démission
tous les manques que sont aussi en
contrepartie les unes des autres les
soixante dix mille sept cent mille
milliards de produits dérivés certes
cédé contrepartie la plupart entre les
banques si un jour vous faites moi en
disant que tout les engagements les
banques sont déliées de tout engagement
il reste pratiquement plus rien puisque
tout ça c'est des paris des espèces
d'assurance réciproque de dans les
produits dérivés vous avez des
assurances sur les sûretés cds si demain
vous dites les cds s'est terminée les
banques ne paieront pas vous des déliés
d'engagement la totalité des produits
dérivés de cds est terminée c'est juste
que vous n'avez plus de l'assurance sur
les gens qui se pensaient rembourser
mais déjà cette partie sur les dérivés
c'est attention alors dit là je pense
qu'il ya eu un une excellente leçon je
pense qu'elle n'a pas été agressée
nature et bien vous réveiller il ya une
excellente question le son qui a été la
bns il ya des gens qui se croyait
couvert aussi sauf qu' il soit ils n'ont
pas été couverts parce qu'il ya pas
exploitation donc tous ceux qui avaient
mis des stops et c'est pour pour pour
limiter leurs pertes se sont retrouvés
avec des pertes gigantesques donc
attention à ça on se croit souvent
beaucoup plus couverts qu'on est
d'accord mais on a vu aussi à chypre une
belle expérience communiste puisque
c'est ce qui est devant nous quand même
hein où la suite à la faillite de
quasiment c'était les deux plus grosses
banques du pays mais c'était
pratiquement les deux seules banques du
pays certes avec une aide européenne
derrière enfin au final vous avez mis la
garantie des dépôts à 100000 euros puis
tous les personnes qui avaient 5
millions d'euros sur son compte il doit
y rester 200 ou 300 milles c'est qu'une
partie on est d'accord que problèmes
antérieurs logan ça c'est rien du tout
il ya ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
ça ne s'annonce à n'engager pas plus que
ça c'est comme quand la société générale
perd 5 milliards c'est simple il ya un
jour où ce sera 500 il va se passer quoi
il va se passer que là on sera pas bien
c'est à dire que l'état français ne
pourra pas mettre les ans environ on est
déjà largement surendettés donc
c'est tout est une question de
proportions quand quand vous devez 1000
euros à votre banquier vous avez des
ennuis quand vous lui devez un milliard
d'euros c'est lui qui a désormais les
yeux que voilà c'est toujours la même
chose donc c'est tout est une question
de proportion d'accord hervé un dernier
mot un dernier mot dernier un ami le
dernier dernier c'est de dire que
le pessimisme et de sentiments
l'optimisme et de volonté et qu'il n'ya
pas de fatalité
nous pouvons à travers différents
mécanismes nous isoler d'un certain
nombre d'événements et nous pouvons
gérer notre intériorité française
financière industrielle sociale
avec prudence et discernement ce que
nous faisons depuis un demi siècle donc
moi j'ai je crois que les problèmes ont
augmenté que nous avons bien fait de
parler des états unis parce que c'est le
centre du problème et que nous pouvons
nous organiser
pour
prévoir cette nouvelle crise qui peut
arriver mais peut aussi ne pas arriver
et qu'elle n'est pas un impact délétère
sur nous tous
messieurs merci
à partir du moment où on autorise les
opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent sur
le réseau en fait on les autorise à
modifier la société on les autorise à
modifier la façon dont les gens
interagissent entre eux sont mieux il ya
de plus en plus d'opportunités deux ou
plus en plus de savoir et de talent de
plus en plus de solutions et de plus en
plus de capitaux pour des projets c'est
à dire que ce qui manque à l'heure
actuelle
que dans beaucoup de pays ont fait
évoluer le cadre institutionnel pour
inclure la société civile dans le débat
et on est très loin de faire ça en
france
pensez même un peu la terreur des
institutions